pharmaunternehmen weltweit stoppen die
forschung an den wichtigsten
arzneimitteln überhaupt antibiotika
dabei nimmt die zahl resistenter keime
immer weiter zu und das ist eine der
größten globalen gefahren überhaupt noch
die gesundheitskonzerne halten die
entwicklung neuer wirkstoffe als für
nicht profitabel genug und mit
krebspatienten beispielsweise lässt sich
viel schneller und einfacher viel mehr
geld verdienen
bot allerdings es gibt einen
lösungsvorschlag klicks um
science-fiction gibt es denkt die
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und activity glocke nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen immer wieder berichten wir
hier bei pixum science fiction über
eines der gefährlichsten globalen
probleme überhaupt multiresistente keime
die selbst von den vereinten nationen
als die größte und dringendste gefahr
überhaupt bezeichnet werden schon in
einigen jahren könnte es mehr tote durch
infektionen durch medikamenten
resistente keime geben als durch
krebserkrankungen ab dem jahr 2050
könnte es pro jahr zehn millionen tote
durch resistente keime geben es scheint
so als seien wir den superkeim schutzlos
ausgeliefert bereits heute sterben immer
wieder menschen unter den augen von
ärzteteams an bakteriellen infektionen
und das obwohl ein antibiotikum nach dem
anderen verabreicht wird doch ohne
erfolg
jetzt sind journalistinnen und
journalisten vom norddeutschen rundfunk
zu einem alarmierenden recherche
ergebnis gekommen
demnach entwickeln pharmaunternehmen
weltweit kaum noch neue wirkstoffe in
diesem zusammenhang die forschung an
neuen antibiotika wird teilweise sogar
gestoppt und das obwohl die zahl
resistenter keime zunimmt das problem
die forschung in diesem bereich ist wohl
nicht lukrativ genug oder rechnet sich
gar nicht ja das klingt nach einer
katastrophe mit ansage dabei gab es noch
in den vergangenen jahren große
ankündigungen in diesem bereich 2016
hatten sich etwa 100 unternehmen zu
sogenannten ema industriell 1
zusammengetan um den resistenzen den
kampf anzusagen dabei unter anderem
namhafte pharmaunternehmen wie novartis
sanofi und johnson & johnson damals
versprach man sich in der antibiotika
entwicklung einzusetzen und in diese
forschung zu investieren
doch die ndr recherche zeigt ein anderes
bild fast 50 prozent der unternehmen die
sich in der industrie allianz
zusammengetan hatten forschen
mittlerweile nicht mehr im bereich der
antibiotika laut einschätzung von
fachleuten beschäftigen sie
weder die großkonzerne allergan oder
pfizer noch johnson & johnson im großen
stil mit der entwicklung von neuen
antibiotika auch novartis und sanofi
sind raus ein ähnliches bild auch bei
den kleineren unternehmen der branche
von den unternehmen die 2016 die
entsprechende erklärung unterzeichnet
haben haben 20 in der zwischenzeit die
insolvenz angemeldet oder haben die
forschung an antibiotika wirkstoffen
aufgegeben sprich da gibt es einen
zusammenhang zwischen insolvenz und
forschung zur antibiotika verständlich
dass dann die unternehmen die forschung
in diesem bereich scheuen wie der teufel
das weihwasser auch hier ist eben
derselbe grund finanziell lohnt sich das
nicht mehr
denn nicht nur die entwicklung eines
antibiotikums schlägt mit mehreren
hundert millionen euro zu buche
hinzu kommen die kosten für die
herstellung die vermarktung und den
vertrieb
doch nicht nur das ist alles andere als
profitabel auch die anwendung von
antibiotika ist nicht wirklich lukrativ
da erkrankte die mittel ja meistens nur
einige tage einnehmen zudem werden neue
mittel in diesem bereich für den notfall
gebunkert für den worst case nämlich
dann wenn die gängigen antibiotika nicht
mehr anschlagen den pharmaunternehmen
ist schon lange klar dass sich mit
anderen mitteln viel mehr geld verdienen
lässt zum beispiel mit krebsmedikamenten
oder aber mit wirkstoffen die bei
chronischen erkrankungen helfen sollen
und so ziehen sich die konzerne aus
diesem bereich zurück nur noch vier der
25 größten pharmafirmen sind laut der
ndr recherchen in diesem bereich tätig
inwieweit sie sich da ins zeug legen wie
viele mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter
dabei sind und wie viel geld die
konzerne investieren dass es nicht
bekannt fachleute äußern sich sehr
besorgt über diese entwicklung so auch
die vero also die beraterin der
weltgesundheitsorganisation nur salat
teures bacher im interview mit der ard
sendung panorama für mich ist absolut
klar dass die pharmaindustrie eine
verantwortung für die gesellschaft hat
vertreter aus der pharma branche dagegen
sind der meinung dass der fehler im
system liegt der vorsitzende der ma
industriell 1 thomas cueni
beispielsweise sieht keinen markt für
antibiotika erstellt die folgende frage
warum sollte ein unternehmen in einem
bereich investieren in dem das risiko
hoch sein dass die forschung nicht
erfolgreich ist die super spannende ndr
recherche zeigt eines ganz deutlich
nämlich dass in diesem lebenswichtigen
bereich das marktwirtschaftliche system
versagt dabei sollte die pharmaindustrie
in die verantwortung gezogen werden wenn
die zahlen zeigen dieser branche geht es
derzeit richtig gut
mit wirkstoffen gegen krebs und
chronische erkrankungen kamen die
größten konzerne zusammen im jahr 2018
auf mehr als 100 milliarden euro gewinn
nicht umsatz gewinn an lebenswichtigen
medikamenten aber wird gespart und die
forschung wird eingestellt weil dieser
bereich nicht profitabel genug ist das
alles wird fatale folgen für uns bzw
für die nächsten generationen haben ohne
wirksame antibiotika ist die moderne
medizin machtlos infizierte wunden oder
lungenentzündungen bedeuten dann nämlich
das todesurteil so wie früher als es
noch keine antibiotika gab und es ist
allerhöchste zeit denn die entwicklung
neuer medikamente passiert nicht von
heute auf morgen dafür können gut und
gerne mal 15 jahre ins land gehen
rein wirtschaftlich gesehen ist der
rückzug der pharmaunternehmen in der
antibiotika forschung nachvollziehbar
doch das alles ist eine entscheidung
über leben und tod deswegen ist es
wichtig dass die rahmenbedingungen zu
unserer aller wohl geändert werden heißt
also hier müssen politische
entscheidungen her denkbar wäre
beispielsweise ein globaler fonds zur
antibiotika forschung alle
pharmakonzerne müssen einzahlen doch nur
die die in diesem bereich forschen
würden von diesem geld profitieren wie
wir selber superbakterie züchten
anklicken anschauen und doktor watson
hammer kanal abonnieren bis dann bleibt
dran